♪ ♪
>> Bret: THE OPTION TO USE
ACTIVE DUTY FORCES IN SHOULD ONL
BE USED AS A MATTER OF LAST
RESORT AND ONLY IN THE MOST
URGENT OF DIRE SITUATIONS.
WE ARE NOT IN ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS NOW.
I DO NOT SUPPORT INVOKING THE
INSURRECTION ACT.
>> IF THE CITY OR STATE REFUSES
TO TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO DEFEND THE LIFE AND
PROPERTY OF THEIR RESIDENCE,
THEN I WILL DEPLOY THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY AND
QUICKLY SLOPE THE PROBLEM FOR
THEM.
>> Bret: WELL, BREAKING RANKS
TODAY SAYING WHAT HE SAID TO
REPORTERS THIS AFTERNOON.
AND LATE IN THE AFTERNOON.
RETURNING, REVERSING A DECISION
TO SEND SOME 200 ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY AROUND THE WASHINGTON
D.C. AREA BACK TO THEIR HOME
BASE.
WHAT NOW?
THERE ARE REPORTS THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE ADMINISTRATION,
THE PRESIDENT, UPSET.
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN?
LET’S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
ARI FLEISCHER.
IT WAS INTERESTING TO WATCH THE
SPIRIT AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> YEAH, I WAS STUNNED ACTUALLY.
I WOULDN’T HAVE SUSPECTED THE
DEFENSE SECRETARY TO BREAK WITH
THE PRESIDENT LIKE THIS.
I DON’T REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE LATER MOVED TO BRING BACK
THOSE TROOPS MEANS.
BUT HE READ FROM A STATEMENT.
THIS WAS KNOCKED OFF THE CUFF.
HE IS BREAKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THE INSURRECTION
ACT.
HE ALSO HAS CLEARLY HAD SECOND
THOUGHTS ABOUT A COMPANY NAME
THE PRESIDENT.
HE DID REFER TO IT AS A
PHOTO OP.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE HOW HE
COULD STAY ON IN THE CABINET
AFTER THIS.
BUT, WE WILL SEE.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS VERY CAREFUL
TODAY.
THEY DID NOT SAY THE PRESIDENT
HAD FAITH IN HIM, JUST THAT WE
HAVE TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Bret: ARI, YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH ADMINISTRATIONS WHETHER
A TURNOVER OF DIFFERENT
OFFICIALS.
BY NOW YOU HAVE A FORMER DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
WITH THIS SCATHING COMMENTARY IN
THE ATLANTIC.
SAINT DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST
PRESIDENT OF MY LIFETIME WHO
DOES NOT TRY TO UNITE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, DOES NOT EVEN
PRETEND TO TRY.
INSTEAD HE TRIES TO PROVIDE US.
HE GOES ON IN A PRETTY LENGTHY
ARTICLE, ARI, WOULD YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
THIS DELIBERATE EFFORT OF JOY IN
COUNTRY APART?
>> SCATHING IN HIS RIGHT.
THAT PIECE WAS VERY TOUGH ON THE
PRESIDENT.
AND IT GOT RIGHT TO THE FAULT
LINE IN OUR SOCIETY.
HOW DIVISIVE THE PRESIDENT CAN
BE.
HOW DIVISIVE THE TIMES WE LIVE
IN ARE.
I THINK WE ARE EQUALLY DIVISIVE
BACK TO THE PRESIDENT.
BUT CLEARLY FOR GENERAL MATHIS
AS HE REACHED HAS BREAKING
POINT.
HE IS UNCOMFORTABLE IN WHAT HE’S
SEEN.
IT’S EXTRAORDINARY THAT A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE CABINET WOULD
CRITICIZE THE MAN WHO GAVE HIM
THAT POSITION IN SUCH BLUNT
TERMS.
IT’S A SIGN OF THE TROUBLE OF
THE PRESIDENT IS IN.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON’T WANT TO BE A
PRESIDENT WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH
GREAT DIVISION WHERE YOU ARE
LOSING FORMER ALLIES.
ESPECIALLY IN AN ELECTION YEAR.
SO I DO THINK THIS IS A
TROUBLESOME SIGN OF PEOPLE WHO
WANT SUPPORTED THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, THE LAW AND
ORDER PITCH THE PRESIDENT
SAYS -- YOU OFTEN DOMINATE THE
STREETS, MOE.
YOU’VE SEEN THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT TO ANNOUNCE THE
RIOTING AND LOOTING BUT SUPPORT
PROTESTERS.
THE PRESIDENT HAD SIMILAR WORDS
ABOUT A PEACEFUL PROTEST.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT’S KIND OF
ONE VERSUS THE OTHER.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS AS WE GET
READY FOR THIS ELECTION?
>> YEAH, AND I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THE PRESIDENT HAS IS
HE SAYS THE RIGHT THINGS ABOUT
PEACEFUL PROTESTS.
BUT THEN IN FRONT OF THE WHOLE
WORLD WITH CAMERAS ROLLING,
AUTHORIZES A MILITARIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO USE EXCESSIVE
FORCE AGAINST PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS.
ON HIS WAY TO THE CHURCH.
SO IT’S A REAL PROBLEM.
LOOK, I GOT WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
SPEAKING ABOUT LAW AND ORDER.
RIGHT?
I MAY BE A DEMOCRAT, BUT I DON’T
LIKE THE RIOTING IN THE STREETS.
THAT NEEDS TO STOP.
THOSE PEOPLE NEED TO BE FULLY
PROSECUTED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF OUR ABILITY TO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST.
AND I THINK WHAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY BE MISCALCULATING
A BIT IS THE TOUGH "LAW & ORDER"
COMMENTS YOU MAY BELIEVE THAT
CAN HELP THEM POLITICALLY.
I THINK THERE’S SOMETHING THAT’S
A LITTLE BIT MORE AT DEFINING
RIGHT THERE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
AND THAT IS CHAOS.
THAT IS THE COMPLETE AND TOTAL
SENSE OF CHAOS IN OUR GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT, WHERE THE PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO DEAL WITH TWO
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT CRISES WITH
THE PANDEMIC AND THE RACIAL
TROUBLE AND THE RIGHT SPIRIT.
TWO INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS.
AND HE CAN’T GET A HOLD OF THEM.
IT SEEMS TO BE GETTING AWAY FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND THE ECONOMY IS GOING INTO
FREE FALL.
THE POLITICAL CALCULUS MAY BE
BILLEDTHAT LAW AND ORDER WORKS.
I KNOW THERE’S A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT’S ELITE WE ARE
DONE WITH THE COWS.
WE NEED A STEADY HAND OF
LEADERSHIP.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE LAST PART
ABOUT THE ECONOMY GOING INTO
FREE FALL.
THERE ARE POSITIVE SIGNS.
THE MARKET REALLY LOVED THAT
TODAY.
THERE MAY BE KIND OF TURNING THE
CORNER, WE WILL SEE HOW THE REST
OF THE WEEK GOES.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT TALKING TO
BRIAN THIS MORNING.
>> THEY BURNED DOWN THE CHURCH T
BEFORE.
THETHEN WHY DID THEY PRINT ON TH
CHURCH?
THEY MOVED THEM OUT.
WHEN I WENT, I DIDN’T SAY OH,
MOVE THEM OUT.
I DO KNOW WHO WAS THERE.
I FIGURED I WAS GOING TO WALK
OVER TO THE CHURCH VERY NEARBY.
MOST RELIGIOUS LEADERS LOVE THAT
THAT.
>> Bret: MARA?
>> YES, THEY USED PEPPER SPRAY.
THEY CLEARED THE MOB.
THERE WERE SMOKE IN THE AIR,
PEOPLE WERE COUGHING.
AND TEARING UP.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TRYING TO SEND TO MESSAGES.
IT’S JUST THAT ONE IS MUCH
LOUDER THAN THE OTHER.
THE "LAW & ORDER" MESSAGE VERSUS
THE HEALING MESSAGE.
HE ACTUALLY HAS A YOUTUBE AD UP
TODAY WITH HIS REMARKS FROM THE
SPACE LUNCH WHICH WERE ALL ABOUT
HEALING.
BUT YOU DON’T HEAR THAT.
WHAT YOU HEAR IS THE TOUGH
"LAW & ORDER" MESSAGES.
IN TERMS OF LOVING IT, THERE
WERE A LOT OF RELIGIOUS LEADERS
WHO CRITICIZED IT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
AND MAYBE IT WILL WORK.
IN THE PAST, "LAW & ORDER"
MESSAGES HAVE WORKED FOR THEM
WHEN THERE ARE VIOLENT PROTESTS.
BUT THEY MADE A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT, IT IS NOT JUST BELOW LAW
AND ORDER, HE IS THE PRESIDENT
OF CHAOS AND DISRUPTION.
THAT’S SOMETHING NOT PEOPLE
MIGHT JUST BE EXHAUSTED BY.
>> IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE ALL
THE PUSHBACK ABOUT THAT WALK
ACROSS THE STREET.
OBVIOUSLY, FROM EVEN THE
RELIGIOUS LEADERS FROM THAT
CHURCH, BUT NOT A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT THE BURNING CHURCH.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT LAST NIGHT.
LAST WORD HERE?
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE OF THE TEA
PARTY SURROUNDED THE WHITE HOUSE
WHEN OBAMA WAS IN THERE?
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID I WANT TO
GO VISIT THE CHURCH.
AND THEY MOVED PEOPLE AWAY SO WE
COULD VISIT.
YOU WOULD BE PRAISED BY THE
MEDIA FOR SENDING EVERY RIGHT
MESSAGE.
WHAT I HEAR.
AND YOU KNOW THE PRICE WILL BE
ALL OVER THOSE TEA PARTY
PROTESTERS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THEY WOULD SAY SOME ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE THINGS THAT THEY
MOVED THE PROTESTERS.
THIS IS HYPOCRISY AT THE HIGHEST
ORDER.
I THOUGHT FRANKLY,, HE MARCHED
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO GO TO
CHURCH.
THERE IS A LOT OF PART OF THE
SYMBOLISM OF THAT.
QUITE IMPORTANT.
>> Bret: THEY GIVE ALL, WE
HAVE TO RUN.
>> OKAY, I KNOW.
YOU’VE MADE YOUR POINT CLEAR.